i'm sure you've been asked this question
before but i'm curious i i did a q a
with a bunch of students not too long
ago and one of them stood up and because
your show's so popular one of them said
what would you
ask me what i would do in a zombie
apocalypse and i actually
it must be a thought that runs through
your mind yeah yeah i mean
like if you were in that situation what
would you do
i'll be honest i just get bit you know
what i mean like what if okay how about
this my theory what if walkers actually
have it really good what if zombies have
it really good
like what if they're walking around and
all the time
like maybe it's an orgasm the entire
time
you're gonna be like yeah and that's why
they're groaning and moaning like wow
that's awesome i've never heard this
theory or what if like
no no
[Applause]
it's awesome maybe it's awesome to be a
walker yeah we don't know we assume
exactly
and also what if we as people fresh
taste
like amazing to that you know what i
mean right yeah exactly we're depriving
ourselves
of what could be amazing so you're
saying in a zombie apocalypse
you would immediately the first thing
you do is run into the zombies yeah
get a go get here right put a
little barbecue sauce on get bit
and then have a 24 7 orgasm yeah
and a smorgasbord of like candy and
you're not on the run
no you're not going anywhere it's not
hard for you and you're with your
friends and you're like growing
together you're growing together
man i've never heard anybody have that
theory i'm just saying
i think you know you should rethink what
zombies are all about
you're right yeah we've all got to get
outside of our heads man yeah
think outside think outside the box
we've been yeah this is i'm terrible
andy what would you do i'd head north
in general just as far north where all
those bastards freeze
at night they don't freeze at night they
freeze
who said a zombie will freeze solid in
it in a cold climate
you know my thought my answer was what
head to denver airport
hear me out large spaces you can see
it's tons of food
head to a large airport in a pretty open
area
right lots of food there's uh those
moving sidewalks zombies get stuck on
them walking the wrong way
right you're at the food court eating
waving at them they're
they think they're coming towards you
but they're not denver airport
now you see why they won't let andy and
i be writers on the show